Fragen der Woche werden wir fleißigen
deutschen jetzt doch ein Volk von
streikern mit anderen Worten mutieren
wir alle zu Franzosen ja vorgestern sind
die Tarifverhandlungen für die 2,4
Millionen Beschäftigten von Bund und
Kommunen erstmal krachen gescheitert
jetzt ist Schlichtung angesagt ab Mitte
April droht im Worst Case dauerstreik ja
so wie letzten Montag als auf einmal gar
nichts mehr ging an deutschen Bahnhöfen
und Flughäfen also sagen wir mal so es
wurde medial totales Chaos vorhergesagt
und dann äh was für viele wohl eher
entspannt ja ja wenn man nicht zur
Arbeit kann kann man nicht zur Arbeit
klar für bestimmte Berufe hätte es
besser laufen können trotz super Streik
sogar ziemlich tote Hose am Taxistand
wir haben schon bessere Streiks
wie beim Manta Manta man hätte nach dem
ersten aufhören sollen haben die
Gewerkschaften in der Tarif
Auseinandersetzung das große Besteck zu
früh ausgepackt ist ja die Debatte war
das unverhältnismäßig und dazu gehen die
Meinung in der Bevölkerung naturgemäß
weitauseinander all die Leute die jetzt
streiten das sind die Leute die wir für
unser normales tägliches Leben brauchen
wer mehr wer meckert darüber haben die
Leute in Knall in der Birne ich finde
die Forderungen ohne die Details zu
kennen erst mal
zu hoch
ich habe absolut keine Ahnung von dem
Thema aber eine sehr detaillierte
Meinung
wer die fordert 10,5% mehr mindestens
aber 500 Euro die Eisenbahner wollen
zwölf Prozent beide eine Laufzeit von
einem Jahr die Arbeitgeber bieten 8%
mehr eine Einmalzahlung von 3000 Euro
und das über zwei Jahre nach Inflation
wäre das wohl eine de facto Lohnkürzung
zum Beispiel für diese Busfahrerin ich
habe jetzt 3300 Euro brutto bin aber in
der obersten Gehaltsklasse nach 18
Jahren und die neuen Kollegen die jetzt
anfangen oder demnächst anfangen haben
ca 1000 € weniger und von daher es gibt
viele Kollegen die haben zwei Job und
das kann es irgendwo nicht sein ja keine
Ahnung wie es Ihnen geht aber ich möchte
lieber keinen Busfahrer der direkt von
der Nachtschicht an der Tanke kommt
wie soll man zum Beispiel in Köln mit
Familie und 2300 brutto Leben wie soll
das gehen weil gut für Busfahrerinnen
gibt es natürlich immer noch die
Alternative dass sie nach der Arbeit
einfach weiter in ihrem Bus wohnen
Platz ist ja genug und die Kids schlafen
im Auto eh am besten es gibt zwar kein
Bad aber dafür ja Waschanlagen und mit
dem Geld was man so spart anmiete kann
man jeden Tag bei McDrive essen gehen ne
auch für solche Berufe kämpft gerade
Verdi und wie wichtig das ist sieht man
vor allem an Branchen in denen deutlich
weniger Menschen gewerkschaftlich
organisiert sind im Bereich Körper nahe
Dienstleistungen zum Beispiel ja
Durchschnittseinkommen hier
1722 € brutto ähnlich verheerend oder
soll ich sagen verheerend die Lage in
der Floristik und Gastro-Branche Tarif
Auseinandersetzung funktionieren nur auf
Augenhöhe und deswegen ist unser
Streikrecht so wichtig auch wenn zum
Beispiel die mittelstandsunion das gerne
einschränken würde genau dazu gab es
diese Woche übrigens ich weiß nicht ob
sie es gesehen haben eine wirklich sehr
konstruktive Diskussion bei hart aber
fair
laufen werden entschuldigen
was Sie wissen müssen
Frank Plasberg hatte danach fünf Mailbox
Nachrichten vom neuen Moderator bitte
komm zurück
zu spät zu spät Energie und Lebensmittel
um mal zu erklären warum die Forderung
so gestellt werden Energie und
Lebensmittel sind seit dem letzten Jahr
über 20% teurer geworden ein Beispiel
Kartoffeln sogar 66% teurer Kartoffeln
sind quasi ein status symbol in
Deutschland ja so
Memo an mich selbst Pommes ab jetzt nur
noch zweimal am Tag
ich meine klar die Kommunen als
Arbeitgeber argumentieren wenn wir im
öffentlichen Dienst zu viel bezahlen
müssen wir bei Kitas kürzen oder die
Grundsteuer erhöhen so statt aber hier
Kita Kinder gegen Kanalarbeiter
auszuspielen können wir natürlich auch
die finanzielle Ausstattung der Kommunen
verbessern Marcel Fratzscher Präsident
des Deutschen Instituts für
Wirtschaftsforschung schlägt zum
Beispiel vor die Kommunen zu
entschuldigen so wie Hessen das
erfolgreich vormacht bis dahin hilft nur
sprechöre üben heute ist kein
arbeitszeitklinik und der rambulanz das
ist unser einfordern
warte mal warte mal ich habe es gleich
ich habe es gleich Streik in der Klinik
und der Ambulanz alle Arbeitgeber haben
einen kleinen
ja ich habe es nicht genug geübt
Arbeitgeberverbände die
Arbeitgeberverbände warnen vor
französischen Verhältnissen in
Deutschland französische Verhältnisse
kleine haben sie es nicht ja in Paris
gehen Hunderttausende auf die Straße da
brennbarikaden bei uns sitzt man einen
Montag im Bus und üben sprechöre und
alle drin durch ich sage mal was
Deutschland kommt im Schnitt auf gerade
mal 18 streikt Tage pro Jahr die
Franzosen auf 93 ja das ist so weil
solche Tatsachen kümmern manche Medien
allerdings herzlich wenig weiß irgendwer
mit Medien
irgendwer mit Medien mit Friedrich
[Musik]
alte branchenregel nichts so alt wie die
Zeitung von gestern außer natürlich den
schrulligen Typen die noch ernsthaft
Zeitung lesen viele jüngere googeln
jetzt Zeitung hä also jedenfalls es gibt
Meldungen die unheimlich schnell
vergeben Verkehrschaos Monster streikt
deutscher wird lahmgelegt wir wissen
schon heute die Überschriften vom
kommenden Montag das ist natürlich ein
bisschen riskant wenn schon vorher
beschlossene Sache ist Montag
Vollkatastrophe Weltuntergang zurück aus
der Zukunft hatten sich dann alle
allerhand zurechtgelegt so Nachrichten
zum Kotzen breaking news die
Bild-Zeitung z.B hämmerte schon vorher
auf den Warnstreik ein wenig Gutes und
weiß sagte mega streitig Deutschland
lahm um ganz sicher zu gehen hatte die
Redaktion ihren Hubschrauber an den
einzigen Ort im Universum geschickt muss
sowieso garantiert 365 Tage im Jahr Stau
gibt das Leverkusener Kreuz ein mega
Streik wie es ihnen seit Jahrzehnten
nicht gegeben Unternehmen hat also der
Berufsverkehr dort dicht schon in diesem
Moment der genau hinschaute sagt hey der
Berufsverkehr ist aber durchaus nicht
der einzige der hier gerade richtig
dicht ist so ist es Thomas lahm liegt
das glaube ich das richtige Wort denn es
geht fast nichts mehr
ich sehe was was du nicht siehst
fließender Verkehr ist sogar ein
Leverkusen ausgerechnet an diesem Montag
meldet auch der ADAC Pech gehabt bei
Bild wurde spontan überlegt mit der
Bordkanone des Helikopter den gelben
Engel abzuschießen aber auch die anderen
Medien hatten ihren Not ein Ereignis zu
berichten dessen wesentlichen daraus
bestand dass ich nicht ereignete hier
fließt wirklich gar nichts
gespenstische Atmosphäre Geister
Atmosphäre wir sehen das Live-Bild es
ist einfach leer auch hier geht heute
nicht es ist absolut nichts los und im
Gegensatz zu Berlin sind hier auch nicht
50 JournalistInnen sondern nur ich wir
verstehen nur Bahnhof und freuen uns
aber dass die Bundesbahn überhaupt noch
genug Bahnhöfe für alle Reporter hat
wenn man mit dem schieren nicht so viel
Sendezeit ergaunern kann will auch der
Pressesprecher der Bahn mitmachen
ja beim streiken macht der Bundesbahn
einfach niemand was vor die
katastrophenprophezeiung die sich nicht
erfüllt hat war das ist paradox
vermutlich genau das so eine self-lind
Professor die Bürgerinnen und Bürger
waren gewarnt blieben also daheim
äußerten oft Verständnis für den Streik
und manche fanden sogar Gelegenheit für
ihre
abseitigen Neigungen wenn man schon die
Möglichkeit hat einen leeren Bahnhof zu
sehen dann schaut man sich natürlich als
Eisenbahnfan auch einen leeren Bahnhof
an ja das wird spannend wenn die
Müllabfuhr streikt viel Spaß in der
Tonne diese deutschen streitbürger
zeigten einer Gelassenheit man möchte
fast sagen ein Einlässe fährt das zu den
berüchtigten französischen Verhältnissen
passt unser orange wurde für Paris auch
im Streik immer galant fragen
Exklusion war Madame haben sie Feuer
zu Hause hat unter der ist auch die
Bild-Zeitung mitbekommen dass sie sich
über eine Katastrophe aufgeregt hat die
sie sich selbst ausgedacht hatte
flopstreik und sie wollten die Arbeiter
Faust tönte ein Kommentar statt einer
Entschuldigung für ihre Fieber Fantasien
Koffern die gleich weiter gegen die
Gewerkschaften und jetzt stellt man sich
das heimische Grinsen der Redaktion dazu
noch vor und dann weiß man wo die
Arbeiter Faust gerade gerne hin möchte
naja genau ja die Zuschauer mittlerweile
fast alle versteckten Symbole hier bei
uns im neuen Studio gefunden
Illuminati Freimaurer Staatsfunk ist
alles dabei wann wollen wir denn die
eigentlichen Strippenzieher bekanntgeben
es bei so vielen Abonnenten auf Youtube
boah also ich würde mich ranhalten